nice to meet you guys nice to meet you i
love this video thank you thank you it
kind of like made me want real
basketball to be shot this way oh yeah
it
looks cool itself
close-ups of this guy's face talking
trash you took interest to me yeah you
deserved every bit of trash i gave you
he learned spanish just to talk [ __ ]
about me yeah
about my family about my mom
oh my god it was part of the movie in
real life i love his parents
i like you as a basketball coach me too
like what does this all mean
i was just basically i mean i
met a lot of scouts a lot of coaches
they gave me so much
uh
inside stuff that i didn't know about
but i was just
basically doing my father's
in real life dad when he used to coach
my teams growing up his kind of demeanor
he was cool
he'd get he'd push you but then he'd
also say like all right i see my kid's
about to snap let me uh pull back a
little bit and i would do that with old
bo crews over here wow yeah what was he
like in basketball did you get to catch
him off camera yeah he's a great
basketball player
he loved basketball i always say like he
probably watch more basketball than half
of the nba players yeah yes i do watch a
lot he he watch all my games he takes me
after the games even if i play bad i go
one for nine one rebound yeah he was
like but what a rebound you got
he's crazy support i mean he watched
basketball i don't know the last 40
years he know everybody you know you can
talk to him about anything any
championship any team and he know so he
was not as good as you know and he can
play we got pika games we play after the
movie in the movie uh lunchtime whatever
it's all about sweating off meatballs
yes that's why i do apparently i like
kfc i got the tea i heard you and kfc
got it interesting yeah yeah they they
do they do it's a sad relationship
they're happy about it i'm sad
kenny said you had the most hustle i
said who in the cast has the most hustle
and he said it was you really yeah he
said you were in spain writing a script
for another oh yeah yeah that's true no
i work hard i do work hard i don't know
why i get
once i say yes to some commitment then
i'm in it i work my butt off i try to
make it as good as i think it can be but
yeah i'm a little overwhelmed at times
yeah i see juancho running around doing
this young life and i start going maybe
i shouldn't do so much to be like
juancho
no but he works a lot i mean he sleep
a few hours uh we we shooting at the
morning and i asked him but you you get
some rest i say no after we shooting i
going to play two hours pick a game then
i'm working on the script then i have
dinner with my family and then i
couldn't sleep i was like what yeah yeah
but no honestly this guy
working out like a pro yeah
and memorizing his lines and then being
so scared every day he'd have to wake up
an hour earlier to kind of mentally
prepare oh my god i'm with adam
today every single day incredible what a
moment i know
congratulations thank you
yes of course no i i don't you know what
was great just like you when i was young
i didn't even know
it couldn't happen i was so just like i
gotta make this happen i gotta i gotta
become a comedian i gotta get on
saturday night live one day i gotta do
that i was very driven
and
and every time i got rejected i would
just be like yeah okay well they didn't
get it they didn't get it i gotta get i
got to keep going forward so i was
nutty back then i don't know if i'd be
like that now i'm a little too
uh
aware now that that
that it's difficult to get get your
dream back then i was just possessed
yeah
stupid but i got it done i guess yeah
you did you did it what was it like
working with lebron on this
nobody happier than wancho
yeah but i was so happy i was more happy
with the picture and he came and hugged
me just because they actually
doing all the movie yeah yeah it's a
happy so i said yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't hurt at all no no i get it
he's he's uh um
means a lot to the league means a lot to
the world yes to kids around the world
to to
i mean that's the dream what lebron has
done and yeah an incredible player
incredible
guy and he stands uh
for for great thanks so yes but
you guys talking last night was great
because i saw him like yeah man i i'm
buddies with lebron now yeah awesome
thank you guys thank you so much